[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission où
on parle agriculture alimentation
écologique et un peu politique et cette
semaine nous recevons une invitée
exceptionnelle Carole Bouquet bonjour et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
je suis très content d'être autour d'une
table à l'Assemblée nationale je me
demandais si ça existait tout le temps
si c'était prévu en permanence vous
allez voir et avec moi pour présenter
cette émission Jean-Pierre Montanet
bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour Carol
bouquet vous êtes l'une de nos plus
grandes actrices françaises comédiennes
aussi révélée au cinéma en 1977 par
Louis Bunel dans cette obscure objet du
désir très en plus tard vous obtenez le
César de la meilleure actrice dans trop
belle pour toi de Bertrand Blier mais
c'est en 1981 que le grand public vous
découvre vous êtes notre French James
Bond Girl dans Rien que pour vos yeux
avec Roger Moore alors il est comment
Roger Moore vous jouez aussi racine au
théâtre dans Phèdre et encore au début
de l'année Bérénice vous êtes aussi
l'égérie du parfum Chanel numéro 5 la
classe
ce n'est que l'on sait moins c'est que
vous êtes une amoureuse du vin au point
d'exploiter des vignes dans l'île de
pentecelleria au large de la Sicile
proche de la Tunisie un domaine devenu
une terre d'adoption dont vous
connaissez tous les codes toutes les
ambiances toutes les couleurs à l'image
de votre vin le sangoe Doro de l'or
alors pour l'accompagner et bien un
simple poulet grillé Jean-Pierre so chic
forcément sublime et en dessert oups du
fromage avec du roquefort bravo dans le
dessous des plats à la découverte de
pentecelleria et de son Pasito bonissimo
le Sango et Doro le vin de Carol bouquet
dans les pieds dans le plat un Top Chef
éco-responsable dans les étoiles
Thibault Spiewak décroche son premier
macaron au Michelin
allez on passe à table et tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
[Musique]
alors Carole Bouquet souvent à votre
place des députés réclament un plat de
leur terroir la tarte au Maroilles pour
les élus du Nord les coquilles
Saint-Jacques pour les Normands avec ce
poulet rôti du dimanche comme on dit en
fait vous vous en profitez pour rendre
hommage à votre territoire qui est le
cinéma comme vient de dire Brigitte
figurez-vous que le 7e art souvent mis
cette volaille à l'honneur dans ses
titres de films quels qui peut-être
disent quelque chose de vos tourments à
propos du poulet et oui question
cruciale poulet aux vinaigre ou tendre
poulet il y a des bas ou encore poulet
frites délicieusement régressifs mais
pas très régime et même lorsqu'il est
encore fumant sur la table Carole vous
êtes troublé par ce dilemme cornélien
l'aile ou la cuisse d'ailleurs je l'ai
vu sous mes yeux quand on vous a
présenté l'assiette ce qui est sûr c'est
que jamais vous ne direz adieu poulet il
est irremplaçable dans le panthéon des
gueuletons avec votre tribu alors pour
que cette passion résiste aux
contraintes de l'exil sur l'île de
pentecellaria battu par les vents j'ai
fait le job pour vous la parole bouquet
en débusquant sur la Via Giovanni Meli à
pantellariam un poulet rôti de
compétition chez Pipo il boit une gousse
taillot alors qui de ce combat de coq
sortira vainqueur le poulet rôti chérie
ou la pasta que vous vénérez pour les
rôti ou pasta vous me posez une question
impossible
en France pour les rôti en Italie pasta
voilà comme ça chacun dans son camp le
choix de cette volaille c'est parce que
vous aimez tout simplement les plats
simples un simple poulet rôti comme ça
c'est ce qui vous fait plaisir je
préfère les cuisines les plus simples
très bien faites mais plus simple les
plus et entre autres le poulet va
divinement bien avec le étrangement même
avec le sang et l'euro on va le goûter
évidemment
vous vous aimez cuisiner
je cuisine très peu maintenant je
cuisine à énormément quand mes enfants
étaient petits ou même adolescent et
parce que j'avais une grande maison avec
un jardin même à Paris et il y avait
tous les amis qui venaient donc vraiment
les week-ends
[Musique]
pas élever du tout comme ça mais j'ai
découvert sa famille quand j'avais 20
ans et et déjà depuis l'âge de 15 ans de
toute façon à partir du moment où je
suis allé dans le midi c'est tablé
immense et ses couleurs et c'est c'est
odeurs me
fasciner
c'est ça et vous étiez tout seul au
fourneau derrière pour cuisiner pour
tout chacun donne un peu un petit coup
de main pendant longtemps j'étais toute
seule et puis après j'ai eu de l'aide
heureusement et puis à peindre les
rivière j'ai de l'aide parce que parce
que quelquefois on est on est minimum 12
mais on est 15 on est 20 on est 25 on
est 30 on est 40 on va jusqu'à quelle
heure et ce sont des plats italiens
alors ah ben ce sont que des plats
italiens c'est tous les jours pour vous
dire la vérité c'était toujours les
pâtes tous les jours des pâtes mais
toujours différent
et on prend l'apéritif toujours
d'ailleurs avec un peu de parmesan en
Italie tout le temps il paraît que on va
le voir ça se marie très bien à ce
moment-là l'apéritif après on passe aux
pâtes c'est un poisson un pantaleria
toujours grillé aussi là
[Musique]
et s'il est très gros dans le dans le
four à bois dans lequel on fait les
pizzas ou quatre aussi souvent dans vos
sauces non pas tellement oui
on en met tout le temps mais pas
forcément dans toutes les pâtes
et puis et comme les serres des glaces
parce que j'ai une machine absolument
géniale
[Musique]
qui fait des parce qu'un jour je il y a
10 ans au moins de ça si c'est pas il y
a 15 ans je vais dans un restaurant et
je demande à sorbet au fraise et on
m'amène une chose qui ressemble à une
glace à la fraise et un truc moelleux je
fais non je vous ai demandé un sorbet
s'il vous plaît il me dit c'est un
sorbet je vais non c'est une glace il me
dit écoutez descendez avec moi dans la
cuisine voilà la machine Isabelle
Pacojet voilà la machine qui fait ça
c'est extraordinaire comment ça se fait
on suffit il suffit de presser les
fruits de les mettre dans un bocal que
vous mettez au congélateur et le
lendemain la turbine fait que sans rien
sans ajout de sucre de sans crème sans
rien ça vous fait un sorbet donc c'est
ce que je fais elle était avant de
téléria avec les filles avec les fruits
d'été c'est merveilleux voilà vous
pouvez goûter ce poulet pour nous dire
si quelque chose pour vous parce que ce
poulet rôti là c'est un poulet jaune
pour 40 bouquets c'est un poulet jaune
Label Rouge donc c'est le top du top
alors je vais peut-être pas vous
apprendre grand chose puisque vous êtes
une fan du poulet mais trois choses à
savoir pour réussir un bon poulet rôti
d'abord il faut bien graisser la
volaille Brigitte avec un peu de beurre
de l'huile d'olive avant de l'enfourner
pour être sûr d'avoir un poulet moelleux
à cœur et surtout cette peau
croustillante qui fait le charme de ce
poulet rôti le Must le must c'est de
leiser vous savez ce que ça veut dire
Carole Bouquet
vous devez la vérité non il faut alors
décoller la peau du poulet et glisser
entre avec les doigts du beurre pommade
entre la chair et la peau alors là il
paraît que le résultat phénoménal c'est
une peau comme du parchemin
délicieusement croustillante pour gars
je vais essayer ça doit être sublime
c'est compliqué et puis avec les doigts
il faut pousser le beurre pour garder
des blancs bien moelleux opté pour une
première un premier temps de cuisson
vous placez les blancs de poulet collés
au plat afin qu'il ne soit pas trop
exposé à la chaleur puis pour une
deuxième cuisson le retournant de
manière la faire dorer la peau enfin si
vous aimez le le tordre possible à
arroser le toutes les 10 minutes environ
pour qu'il s'imprègne de son jus ne pas
rater sa cuisson pour cela il faut
respecter la température du four et le
temps de cuisson pour un poulet d'un
kilo environ ce qui est pas très gros il
faut opter pour une heure de cuisson
commencer à 250 degrés et on finit à 280
voilà c'est comme ça que vous l'auriez
fait mais moi j'aime bien mettre une
bêtise comment c'est à 250 et on finit
un peu plus doux à 200 pardon
mais c'est pas grave
moi j'aime bien mettre de l'ail à
l'intérieur alors
et de l'estragon parfois où vous le non
l'assaisonnez ou pas tellement pas
tellement je l'aime vraiment assez
nature et comme j'aime énormément l'ail
c'est pas tellement pour donner du coup
au poulet c'est parce que j'adore manger
les gousses d'ail
de concilier bonne nourriture et bon
pour la santé de l'ail c'est très très
bon pour la santé on parle souvent du
poulet du dimanche et vous y faisait
référence Jean-Pierre est-ce que vous le
dimanche c'est un rendez-vous de la
table vous retrouvez maintenant que je
suis grand-mère c'est moi-même mes
enfants sont partis ils ont leur propre
famille ça allait plus quand il y avait
mes enfants à la maison bien sûr vous
étiez assez maman poule je crois oui oui
enfin maman poule j'adorais être avec
mes enfants donc j'organisais mes
tournages en fonction des dates de
vacances de mes enfants pour pouvoir ne
pas les laisser quand ils étaient tout
petits je les emmener avec moi non pas
sur les tournages mais en tous les cas
dans le lieu où je tournais et puis
parce qu'après je voulais pas que ça lui
retourne la tête et je me souviens de
Paul Rassam un moment donné qui est
l'oncle de Dimitri qui vers 8 ans mais
ce qui était normal pour lui il fait une
projection de films mais mais il y a pas
le
je suis pas sûr c'est une très très
bonne idée et alors j'étais va dire
Dimitri écoute on serait bouché on
l'aurait on voilà on aurait on fait du
cinéma donc normal de faire une
projectionnerai les casseroles on aurait
des casseroles on offrirait des
casseroles et bien là il se trouve que
voilà on fait tous du cinéma autour de
toi donc il y a une projection pour pas
que ça lui tourne trop la tête mais
sinon c'est vrai que je les emmenais
beaucoup avec moi sur les tournages et
puis avec souvent donc comme je
m'arrangeais que ça soit souvent aussi
pendant des périodes de vacances à ce
moment là j'en ai des copains donc pour
pas qu'ils s'ennuient donc j'avais 6 ou
8 enfants souvent avec moi et et puis à
la maison oui les week-ends
[Musique]
vous pouvez improviser tout de suite un
repas donc voilà est-ce que d'autres
cuisines qui vous inspirent on boit
beaucoup l'Italie les pizzas on a pas
parlé des pizzas encore un Brigitte dans
l'épis il y a d'autres cuisines qui vous
inspirent du monde ou pas vous avez
beaucoup voyagé vous avez les tournois
asiatiques vous aimez aussi la cuisine
du Japon énormément
thaïlandaise on dit que c'est une des
meilleures du monde irlandaise
magnifique j'ai essayé vous essayez ça
de temps en temps vous laissez au
restaurant le faire vous essayez vous
êtes
très je suis franco-italienne
mais non c'est parce que je sais pas le
faire et et que quand je vais la manger
récemment justement Paul Moret dans un
restaurant vietnamien dans le quartier
où ils sont tous dans le 13e
magnifique mais je suis incapable de le
faire non non alors la pizza
racontez-nous parce que je crois que
vous avez donc un four à pizza à
Pantelleria c'est pas tous les jours
quand même la pizza c'est pas tous les
jours parce que parce que le problème
c'est que ça se dit et comme elle est
très bonne chez moi c'est qu'on se
retrouve à 5 ans donc c'est pas tous les
jours parce que sinon c'est quand même
un peu fatiguant
vous la faites avec quoi tomate mozza
vous mettez des légumes il y a tout tout
est possible mais moi ma préférée je la
fais avec du gorgonzola de la roquette
et et du piment voilà mais très très
fine et et croustillante c'est pas la
pizza napolitaine alors avec cette pâte
un peu boursouflé un peu alors moi je
l'aime moins celle là et Dieu
il se trouve que c'est un au départ un
Napolitain qui a fait les pizzas chez
moi et pour autant il les faisait quand
même très fine et très et croustillant
c'est peut-être la pizza sicilienne
alors que vous faites qui se rapproche
c'est même pas c'est une pizza
napolitaine version
copier sur le fait que j'adore
effectivement mettre du gorgonzola de la
roquette et du piment c'est absolument
merveilleux et vous avez des bons
producteurs à côté de chez vous à
Ponteilla vous aimez aller à la ferme
faire le marché etc ça par contre quand
elle est rien on a un problème c'est que
tout arrive de Palerme donc moi j'ai un
potager
qu'est-ce que vous avez dans votre
tout ce qui est possible qui peut
pousser dans un potager d'accord donc
fruits légumes enfin légumes et
socialement
j'ai un verger aussi donc j'ai des
fruits mais et le poisson par contre à
peinerias ça ça se trouve autant qu'on
en veuille
j'ai des photos de moi avec des là cet
été justement quelques fois la même
Maine à la maison avec des mérous comme
ça on trouve que les espadon si qui
doivent tourner dans dans
plus
dans le sud de la France et il y en a
encore apporté Leiria mais vous devez
les pêcher vous avez pas le droit de
chercher il faut il faut plonger en
apnée vous avez pas le droit d'avoir des
bombes pour pêcher les mérous donc il
faut vraiment et ça se met en général
dans les rochers ils se cachent bien
mais par contre pour le reste comme tout
vient en bateau de de Sicile et
quelquefois pas de Sicile on peut pas
dire que ce qu'on achète comme produit
il y a pas intérêt si vous allez chez
les gens oui mais dans les magasins
c'est pas forcément ce qu'il y aura de
meilleur ligne de produit rien Lille
produit une chose extraordinaire que
fait une table qui travaille avec moi un
homme mais mais plus cette année parce
que son mari l'a obligé à vendre ses
vaches malheureusement mais elle faisait
une ricotta à une tomate qu'elle nous
amenait tous les matins mais il y a
quelqu'un qui en fait d'autres ça fait
ça fait 25 ans que je mange la sienne et
l'année dernière je savais pas que
c'était pas la sienne et j'ai fait
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire là c'est quoi
ça elle me dit truc qu'il y a une
différence oui il y a une différence
c'est une énorme différence elle me fait
bah oui c'est c'est
et vous l'avez senti non non non non non
non ça mais mais parce que parce que ça
lui faisait tellement de travail mais
donc il y a ça il y a les poissons
ça c'est très typique parce qu'on est
plus près de la de la Tunisie mais sinon
sinon c'est la cuisine Cécilienne
essentiellement alors vous nous avez
parlé de pâtes vous nous avez parlé de
pizza quand on est une actrice une
comédienne on fait attention à sa ligne
non alors
non non
je mange des pâtes même si je suis deux
mois en Italie tous les je ne peux pas
manger des pâtes c'est une c'est-à-dire
c'est une frustration pour moi terrible
donc je mange des pâtes même à midi et
le soir je mange des pâtes à la limite
pas parce que j'ai pas très faim
mais tous les soirs je mangeais pas et
du poisson tous les soirs je mange des
pâtes
parce que c'est ça
nous on met beau alors les Américains on
en parle pas mais on est on est très
loin de ça mais on met trop de sauces on
met trop de sauce et de plus il faut
faire revenir les pâtes alors il faut
une poêle pourrie mais mais j'ai pourri
par là parce qu'elle est pas de bonne
qualité vous savez qu'à un moment donné
j'ai voulu faire il y a 10 ans je vais
les faire une surprise à quelqu'un pour
vraiment lui faire un repas italien je
fais venir quelqu'un qui m'aide en
Italie et
les fameuses poils qu'on ne trouve pas
je vous jure que je les ramène chaque
fois d'Italie pour tous mes amis qui
vont chez moi et me disent allez elle se
trouve là dans n'importe quel magasin
par contre
rien vous allez trouver une poêle la
grande la plus légère et ça coûte rien
c'est la seule manière de faire et les
patates d'été sont plus digestes et font
souvent moins grossir c'est un petit
détail c'est à dire c'est surtout
meilleur ah oui non mais indépendamment
du goût c'est aussi parce qu'en fait moi
je mangeais des nouilles effectivement
c'est pas terrible mais non c'est vrai
que que oui parce qu'à ce moment-là le
le gluten voilà alors on va voir si vous
êtes vraiment incollables c'est le quiz
on vient d'en parler moi j'adore ça et
vous aussi on connaît votre amour pour
les câpres sauriez-vous nous dire dans
lesquels de ces plats et bien le cap
fait partie des ingrédients et présent
dans la recette est-ce que le cap est
présent dans la tapenade
[Musique]
aubergine
oignon alors après il y a plusieurs il y
a certains siciliens qui mettent des
pommes de terre aussi mais non
et on peut mettre aussi des cadres on
peut mettre aussi des cas
à La Romana CAP ou
pasta aux sardines pasta la Sarda
face à la sardine non non et est-ce
qu'on met des Caps dans le vitello
tonnato oui exactement voilà parfait et
la caponata on l'emmène et elles sont
tellement elles sont elles sont
tellement
j'ai dit le cap c'est bien la cape
attention
en italien c'est en eston masculin
le elles sont tellement écrasées les
carbone dans la cabane attaque il y a
aucun goût des cadres dans la capote
c'est vraiment le goût de l'aubergine de
l'aigre-doux de l'oignon et les
meilleurs câpres c'est bien quand elle
arrive on est sûrs
vraiment c'est une coopérative pour les
câpres parce que malheureusement pour le
reste ça m'a le 20 ils sont pas arrivés
j'ai essayé de les convaincre pendant
des années il y a rien à faire j'arrive
pas à les convaincre de de alors qu'ils
se font voler par parler gros
producteurs l'achat c'est pour ça qu'on
perd les terres c'est parce que le
raisin est acheté une misère mais la
coopérative des câbles fonctionne très
bien c'est des cas possède
ça dépend il y a trois tailles
différentes selon normalement avant les
ramassait du mois de juin au mois de
septembre maintenant pendant des mois
parce que ça repousse ça repousse et
maintenant ils ont réduit parce qu'une
question de main d'oeuvre c'est un ras
du sol il fait il fait très chaud alors
attendez on va en parler mais on n'a pas
fini de jouer il y a encore un pour vous
alors on va parler de la pizza que vous
vénérer qui a conquis le monde êtes-vous
un collab sur les grandes dates qui ont
jalonné l'apparition puis la
mondialisation de cette galette automate
je vois faire non non en Chine alors
sauriez vous nous dire si les
affirmations suivantes sont vraies ou
fausses ah le mot pizza entre dans la
langue italienne en 1549 vrai ou faux
pas la moindre idée alors c'est vrai
c'est vrai donc ça fait un bail c'est la
marque américaine Domino's Pizza lancée
en 1958 qui va mondialiser la pizza
malheureusement oui alors pas loin
c'est ça en Provence la pizza se
développe dans les années 60 grâce au
camion pizza
possible vrai et la pizza napolitaine
est protégée par une appellation
vrai ou faux non c'est faux c'est faux
exactement comme vous avez raison ils
ont demandé insister mais il n'arrive
toujours pas à voir leur appellation
protégée pour protéger la fameuse pizza
napolitaine que vous n'aimez pas
d'ailleurs
si si que j'aime bien mais mais je
l'aime chez certains napolitain et moi
j'ai d'autres parce que il y a encore
une fois la pizza c'est comme les pâtes
c'est comme la cuisson des pâtes c'est
très c'est très pas c'est très
particulier mais
[Musique]
comme on en fait ailleurs que Anna et
qu'ils sont très protecteurs alors ça
c'est vrai qu'ils sont très protecteurs
les Italiens entre eux
ils peuvent pas faire DOX si je puis
dire parce que parce que sinon alors
s'ils vont en Amérique elle sera jamais
à New York vous mangerez je sais même
pas si ça existe de manger une bonne
pizza ou même des bonnes pâtes je me
fais mais parce que parce que parce que
les les condiments justement les sauces
sont énormes dessus dire c'est pour ça
que c'est difficile alors en France le
repas Carole Bouquet occupe une assez
large place vous le savez et
particulièrement politique c'est souvent
là que ce nous les de politiques mais
que se fait aussi la petite et la grande
Histoire et c'est la brève de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé Carole Bouquet
de réfléchir à une anecdote pourquoi pas
politique autour d'un repas est-ce que
vous avez une histoire à nous raconter
je vous vois sourire alors j'en ai plein
mais il y en a une que je peux raconter
parce qu'il n'est plus là un soir je dis
à l'Opéra pour un dîner la robe je
dirais il y a je sais très bien il y a
40 il y a 41 ans vous voyez et à ce
moment-là vient d'être élu Mitterrand
sonne à ma porte un monsieur que je ne
connais pas du tout que je reconnais en
ouvrant je suis en robe de chambre j'ai
un enfant qui a trois semaines
et il me dit bonsoir
et je vois que c'est Monsieur Giscard
d'Estaing et
je ne connais pas du tout pas du tout du
tout du tout et ils me disent que je
peux visiter la maison parce que elle
appartenait à des amis à moi qui habite
d'ailleurs au fond de la cour là-bas et
je voudrais voir ce que vous en avez
fait
je vous en prie bon très bien je lui
fais visiter la maison je il voit même
mon fils qui a trois semaines je suis
toujours en robe de chambre à bien
évidemment je lui offre même du
champagne et puis il s'en va point voilà
j'ai été on ne peut plus aimable et puis
je dirais qu'il y a 15 ans
[Musique]
peut-être déjà il y avait 20 ans donc 20
ans après je le rencontre dans un dans
ce dîner justement à la robe et il me
dit je lui dis bonsoir monsieur le
Président et
tant bien élevé et il me répond ah
comme vous me dites bonsoir monsieur le
Président
sent bon vous êtes venus chez moi je
vous ai ouvert la porte je vous ai
montré toute ma maison je les ai fait du
champagne j'avais un bébé que j'étais en
train d'allaiter
il me dit oui mais vous avez pas été
séduite
je ne savais plus quoi du coup on s'est
assis tout le monde par terre tout le
monde sortait de l'Opéra parce que le
dîner se passait dans l'opéra et
on a commencé à discuter il m'a dit mais
enfin c'est impossible pouvoir il y a
rien de plus séducteur pour une femme je
fais écouter vous tombez très mal pas
pour moi et on a commencé à discuter du
pouvoir effectivement le pouvoir de
séduction des hommes politiques sur les
femmes et il avait manifestement qui
doit être très grand parce que ça lui
est pas arrivé souvent que un petit peu
plus de vous mais oui mais
c'est incroyable 20 ans après il me dit
ça et franchement je vous jure j'ai été
extrêmement poli aimable enfin vous
pouvez pas être plus aimable
que ça je fais pas l'inviter à dîner
j'avais mon bébé je lui offert à boire
il a de toute façon il est invité à
dîner à côté donc je sais pas ce que
j'aurais dû faire me cacher dans un
placard avec lui et l'embrasser il était
en quelque sorte assez cash il le
formulait comme ça le pouvoir pourquoi
séduire forcément les femmes il me l'a
dit oui oui mais ce jour-là
il s'attendait au contraire
je lui saute dessus et je dis ben non
mais pas vrai pas vraiment je peux avoir
un peu d'eau il résistible vieux bien
sûr parce que vous racontez plein
d'histoires est-ce que vous êtes invité
parfois à l'Elysée à dîner ça arrive ça
arrive par le président et sa femme et à
ce moment-là ce sont quoi des des grands
dînés où on parle cinéma ou ça dépend
quelquefois ça peut être avec Brigitte
Macron des petits des petits des petits
non pas des petits déjeuners mais des
déjeuners car elle nous aident
énormément la Voix de l'enfant c'est un
sujet où elle est très active sur la
protection de l'enfance
et donc là c'est
et puis sinon c'est plus formel c'est
les dîner c'est les dîners d'État et
vous avez toujours été invité par les
présidents successifs à des dîner j'y
vais peu mais j'y vais de temps en temps
la dernière fois ils m'ont fait c'est le
président Macron m'a fait un Honorine
immense parce que c'était le président
italien et qui avait mon vin à table et
que le président italien j'étais juste
en face de lui
et sicilien ah oui donc on s'est mis à
parler on a fait une chose parfaitement
impolie on s'est mis à parler quelques
secondes en italien et de la Sicile donc
des brèves de comptoir dans les arcanes
du pouvoir vous pourriez presque en
faire un livre
[Musique]
alors on va parler du vin parce que
derrière un bon plat et bien il y a
toujours une bonne bouteille c'est
l'accord mes vins et c'est le dessous
des plats
et pour vous ça commence évidemment
comme un coup de cœur pour cette île
PANELIA entre la Sicile et la Tunisie
aux accents d'Orient vous y plantez vos
racines avant d'y cultiver vos vignes un
pari fou dans cette terre volcanique
vallonnée de terrasse et surtout de
friches 7 ans plus tard vous y
construisez un chat le sangoué Doro est
né et s'exporte désormais à Paris
reportage permis calcarniel et mashallah
dans ce haut lieu de la cuisine
italienne à Paris on vient pour déguster
les linguées au bonne volet cuisine
vénitienne accompagnée par les meilleurs
crus de la botte Brunello kianti et plus
rare le pacito le restaurant fait partie
des quelques tables à proposer le vin de
Carole Bouquet le sang d'or en français
un vin liquoreux de Ponteilla il
volcanique perdus entre la Sicile et la
Tunisie alors nous avons une magnifique
vin ici c'est un mec que nous avons la
carte avec plus aux années donc on adore
belle belle couleur avec des senteurs de
fleur d'oranger amandes magnifiques il
faut compter 37 euros pour déguster un
verre de ce nectar
au Mori Venise bar Alessio Pedrotti le
propose aux gastronome alors ça nous
arrive de le servir aussi
avec du panigiano a fini 36 mois donc ça
peut être en bain de méditation en
apéritif super aussi avec les desserts
donc dans un endroit comme celui-ci
c'est un indispensable à voir c'est
comme nous avons des paroles
nous devons avoir aussi le passé présent
celui de Carole Bouquet il y a une
production de saumon 5000 bouteilles
apparent donc nous sommes très fiers de
pouvoir avoir dans notre restaurant
c'est donc à 2500 km de Paris à
ponte-le-ria sur ce bout de terre balayé
par les bancs que Carole Bouquet produit
son pas si tôt depuis 2005
où est la nouvelle récolte maison ne
devient pas vigneronne en un seul jour
ses responsables et les coupables
entièrement en fait je l'ai emmené dans
la voiture du vin c'est vrai que c'est
un travail très difficile et que
normalement les jeunes ne veulent pas le
faire moi j'ai une chance folle voilà je
le grand-père le petit-fils le fruit de
sa passion pour cette île dont elle a
fait son refuge
[Musique]
un vin qui a valu à l'actrice des trélus
personnalités viticole de l'année 2023
par la Revue du vin de France
quel travail après il y a une deuxième
récolte qui se fait aussi qu'on met à
sécher au soleil qui est pareil se
retourne tous les deux jours pareil
elle a même vers milieu août mais
simplement celle là elle va être encore
humide et
on va la presser avec la vendange qu'on
va faire début septembre donc pour bien
comprendre on parce que moi je suis pas
aussi expert que Brigitte pour le vin on
récolte à trois trois époques
différentes avec trois degrés de
maturation du vin du raisin on récolte
la 3e époques différentes absolument et
la récolte verte la récolte qu'on va
presser se fait début septembre selon le
temps en ce moment ça change mais en
fait tu as pas intérêt à étrangement
comme c'est une île volcanique moi sur
mon île qui est plus proche de la
Tunisie que de la Sicile mais pour
autant j'ai de l'arroser le matin parce
que je suis à 500 m d'altitude et que
les vignes étant enfouies dans le sol et
si vous regardez parce que comme j'ai
fait des travaux tout ça par exemple si
on le coupe ça serait que c'est que de
la roche volcanique et vous voyez des
racines passées à travers la roche
volcanique qui est l'oxygène en plus
pour aller chercher l'eau très très
profond
et donc vous assemblez tout à ce
moment-là on va faire donc on va
mélanger ce qui n'est pas encore du
Malaga se réservoir de Marseille et les
terrasses qu'elle vous faisiez référence
justement voilà
ils le font à la main parce que et
d'ailleurs à un moment donné il y a un
des maires qui pourrir à voulu remettre
les ânes à la mode je vous dis pas la
colère des des paysans mais c'est pas du
tout touristique ça nous a sacrifié
notre vie avec ses parce que moi j'ai
une maison par exemple maintenant il y a
une route mais avant il y avait pas de
route c'était construit par eux par les
paysans alors il y a pas de route dans
les dans les vignes mais pour aller d'un
endroit à l'autre c'est même eux qui ont
fait et comme c'est et comme il y a une
montagne qui fait 900 mètres
il faisait les routes il faisait tout
donc pour l'idée de l'âne qui était très
particulier à Paris c'est moi et mon
camion oui alors là vous êtes dans le
je l'aime tellement ce camion je
l'aurais je l'ai plus garder mais non il
est blanc maintenant il est neuf il est
beaucoup moins bon que celui-là qui est
bleu et
en tout cas cette photo est extra et ben
oui à l'arrière et voilà
ça c'est celui qui m'a suivi dans
l'aventure le premier c'était donc le
grand-père qui est toujours là qui doit
soi-disant ne travaille plus mais
toujours là viens toujours dans
l'échelle et explique toujours à son
petit-fils comment faire et j'ai eu
cette chance énorme d'avoir vous voyez
tout à l'heure lui à l'image son
petit-fils aucun des jeunes ne veulent
plus travailler la terre c'est trop
difficile à travailler la terre à
Pantelleria pour ça coûte très très cher
de produire du du c'est pour ça que le
vin est assez cher aussi c'est pour ça
que c'est très cher à produire je vous
jure que sur ces enlevant à ce prix là
moi je gagne pas d'argent ça me permet
de pas en perdre et de juste si j'ai un
problème de de camion par exemple de
changer un camion ou de changer le
problème de de de
d'un des trucs réfrigérant j'ai j'ai
c'est juste pour faire vivre de votre
passion vous ne gagnez pas l'argent
arriver à gagner un peu tout simplement
pour pouvoir que mes fils s'en occupent
sans avoir à faire tout le travail que
j'ai fait car la partie la plus
difficile c'est la commercialisation du
20 c'est pas c'est pas de faire le vin
c'est très dur de faire c'est des gens
héroïques qui font ça c'est un travail
vraiment très difficile mais quand vous
avez des gens qui sont nés sur cette
endroit et savent le faire j'ai moi en
fait au début je voulais pas faire du
vin du tout pas question que je fasse du
vin je suis arrivé amoureuse de cet
endroit par hasard et pendant des années
j'ai loué une maison et pour aller
il y a un lac aussi apporte les reya qui
est très beau et pour aller dans ce lac
je prenais une petite route qui a ce
moment-là était en terre qui traverse
qui montait dans la montagne et qui
descendait à travers des vignes et je
voyais dans un endroit complètement
vierge de toute lumière de toute sauvage
totalement
et puis je trouvais cet endroit
tellement beau et à un moment donné j'ai
vu sur une maisons pas plus grande que
ce studio encore plus petit même presque
avant et j'ai voulu l'acheter j'ai
appelé une amie architecte et d'ailleurs
elle qui a sauvé
l'architecture de plainte téléria parce
que c'est très particulier ça s'appelle
des damesozo et c'est fait avec ses
pierres volcaniques noires qui sont
mises les unes sur les autres avec ses
trois ronds pour récupérer l'eau
justement qui vont dans des citerne
et elle leur a expliqué que c'était il y
en avait nulle part ailleurs donc
heureusement ils ont commencé à les
aller conserver elle était là maintenant
85 parce que 90 ans elle est arrivée là
juste après ses études d'architecture de
Milan donc elle elle a permis de
conserver toutes ces maisons donc elle
me dit non car il y a pas l'électricité
il y a bien des mains il a pas l'eau
parce que de toute façon l'eau se dit il
faut construire des citernes mais non là
il y a c'est pas possible alors j'ai pas
fait puis l'année d'après quand même je
suis allé voir le notaire et puis j'ai
acheté mon tout petit bout de terre sur
lequel il y avait même pas un hectare
avec ma petite maison pour dire j'aime
tellement l'Italie que j'étais quelque
part
vous êtes peut-être un peu obligé
comment vous dire je suis pas
complètement en bio parce que parce que
parce que je peux pas personne ne peut
vraiment être complètement en bio sinon
on perd toute la production mais il se
trouve que cette personne
et qui a tellement de vent que prête
pratiquement il y a pas de traitement et
que quand le vent qui fait le ménage les
premiers hectares que j'ai acheté on
voit nos yeux qui est là et qui est donc
après avec son petit-fils qui par chance
à bien voulu ne pas quitter Lille et
devenir autre chose que vignerons à
penteleria je vous dis il y en a plus il
y a plus de jeunes plus personne veut
travailler la terre
mais et je vois hier je avant-hier je
parlais avec la femme qui dirige fait
l'ensegur elle et ils ont les mêmes
problèmes à Bordeaux la manœuvre alors
je vous dis pas ce que c'est vu la
dureté du travail et le problème que eux
aussi quand on fait un vin de cette
immense qualité on fait tout à la main
mais quand même on on est à hauteur
d'homme On n'est pas couché au niveau du
sol on n'est pas on n'est pas tous les
deux jours en train de retourner les
raisins il fait très chaud et c'est
vraiment tous les deux jours
le
pacifique et ça sent exactement ça sans
ça dans toute l'île au mois d'août parce
que les raisins sont en train de sécher
mais il avait raison notre
restaurant effectivement à l'abricot
puis là ça peut la fleur d'oranger et
les amandes aussi
moi j'ai plein d'amandiers j'ai plein
d'orangers j'ai plein d'arbres fruitiers
qui sont mélangés dans la parce que
c'était les cultures d'autrefois ils
avaient besoin que tout soit ensemble
après mais là comme c'était des cultures
pour les faire vivre eux et le raisin
par contre au départ ils ont commencé à
faire du vin tard à partir autrefois
c'est du coton ils étaient très riches
avant de téléria malheureusement à
partir du début du 20e
l'économie change il y a plus ce besoin
des navires c'est terminé qui transporte
le coton a dû être concurrencé par les
pays
à ce moment-là Lille vit très bien du
Malaga qu'elle vend c'est à dire du
raisin sec vraiment qu'elle vend mais
il perdent la guerre
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas un scoop
et et il se trouve que le maire de pain
téléréat toute l'île est une pure
merveille le maire de pantalleria
accepté de vider il est moyennant argent
les Américains lui achètent sa ville ont
perdu il accepte d'évacuer la ville
il bombarde la ville alors que la guerre
a gagné il y a aucune raison et cette
ville était d'une beauté il y avait un
opéra quand elle Riha sur cette île que
vous voyez il y avait un opéra c'était
somptueux cette petite ville et comme
elle a été construite dans les années 50
c'est une horreur maintenant mais tout
le reste de l'île par contre est protégé
et moi et en même temps quelque chose
qui est une tendresse folle parce que
des endroits comme ça il y en a pas mal
en Italie beaucoup dus d'ailleurs au
bombardement qui ont qui qui se sont
passés donc si vous avez dans le sud de
l'Italie vous avez des choses
construites dans les années 50-60 et moi
ça m'émeut mais cela dit dans la ville
j'y vais jamais
dire que toute l'île l'île fait quand
même 50 km de long elle a une montagne
qui fait 900 mètres tout tout rien n'est
abîmé moi j'avais pas quand je me suis
installé j'avais pas l'électricité alors
j'ai l'architecte qui qui essaye que je
m'installe pas là et elle me dit Carole
oui mais un groupe électrogène ça fait
énormément le bruit donc tu auras ou
parce qu'elle avait mis chez quelqu'un
juste à côté de moi ou frigidaire ou
lumière chez non je vais avoir et
frigidaire parce je fais du cinéma et
c'est pas vrai mais que les c'est pas
vrai que les groupes électrogènes font
de bruit on tourne avec des groupes
électrogènes donc j'ai largement la
place on va aller le mettre là-bas et
moi j'ai d'ailleurs heureusement parce
que comme en plein août c'est une
malheureusement une compagnie Privée qui
produit l'île ria et qu'ils ont le
monopole s'ils produisent plus ils
perdent monopole donc il y a des
coupures d'électricité en plein été donc
si vous êtes en train de faire un dîner
et alors que c'est le moment il devrait
y avoir vraiment de l'électricité oui
sauf moi puisque à ce moment-là mon beau
vélo se met en route mais j'ai vécu
pendant 10 ans avec un groupe
électrogène avant qu'ils viennent mettre
la lumière mais qui est enfouie dans le
sol donc je n'ai aucune pollution
lumineuse moi je vois comme si j'étais à
2000 mètres d'altitude le ciel vous êtes
conquise en tout cas par cette île de
pantereria vous êtes aussi une grande
amatrice de 20 mais aussi de bonnes
chair alors nous avons décidé de vous
emmener dans un restaurant avec un
macaron et une étoile verte la
restauration responsable on en parle et
on met les pieds dans le plat
oui Brigitte signe des temps le guide
Michelin récompense les restaurants
éco-responsables c'est le cas danona
ouvert en 2019 à Paris déjà récompensé
par une étoile verte Thibault spiwak un
ancien top Chef décroche cette fois un
macaron une consécration pour une
cuisine vertueuse qui ménage aussi bien
la planète et le bien-être au travail de
son personnel c'est un reportage des
deux marions Marion Becker et Marion
Duvauchelle
le but d'ananas c'est d'ouvrir dans
Paris intra-muros un restaurant qui
allait être à la fois gastronomique donc
les techniques de cuisine de service de
salle etc mais extrêmement engagé pour
la planète donc de pouvoir prouver tous
les confrères restaurateurs et aux
clients parisiens qu'on peut manger bien
tout en prenant soin de sa santé et de
la santé de la planète l'étoile permet
de montrer que le niveau de du
restaurant et là en fait et mais le but
d'origine enfin il y avait pas forcément
d'objectif d'étoiles à l'origine du
restaurant nous ce qu'on voulait c'était
vraiment être une référence en matière
d'écologie en restauration parisienne
Thibault utilise des produits
locaux travail les épluchures un
engagement et des initiatives
éco-responsables déjà couronnée par les
toiles vertes des sa création et cette
dernière année on s'est dit que c'est
vrai que si on passait la seconde un
petit peu et qu'on arrivait à avoir des
toiles bah ça rendra encore plus
crédible l'étoile verte et le discours
qu'on prenait au quotidien il y aura
demain en live on les fera genre au
glaçante eau bouillante au glaçante il y
a tous les champignons à faire tomber à
l'huile une première fois déjà cette
première étoile rouge c'est la
consécration
c'était un gros gros moment
d'émotion sauf enfin pour moi pour les
équipes j'avais moi je tremblais dans
tout mon corps j'ai envie de pleurer de
joie les émotion un peu comme en enfance
quand on gagne un match de foot et qu'on
est heureux c'est à peu près la même
emploi maintenant plus dur commence
c'est une nouvelle étape qui commence
c'est avec toujours l'ambition d'aller
plus loin et plus haut sur une réussite
collective
qui avec son équipe et il ne compte pas
changer d'esprit voilà donc on essaie de
recruter de plus en plus pour aussi
avoir de plus en plus de confort de
travail pas qu'on les donne courir comme
dans beaucoup de maisons nous on prend
notre temps trouver des choses bien dans
une bonne humeur et l'étoile permet ça
aussi et permet de d'augmenter les
salaires et de d'améliorer nos
engagements écologiques là on vient de
passer sur le mouvement actuel on est
passé en 100% bio sur toute la partie
crèmerie lait beurre etc etc alors qu'on
était en français 100% mais pas
forcément 100% bio donc là on essaie
vraiment d'aller de plus en plus loin
sur la démarche la farine 100% bio le
sucre 100% etc
elle permet de finalement de pousser nos
engagements encore plus loin et plus de
d'augmenter le nombre d'équipes
d'améliorer la qualité de vie des
équipes et c'est un peu ça pour moi le
la force que nous porte l'étoile
quant à franchir une nouvelle marche la
deuxième étoile c'est un c'est un autre
monde c'est un autre monde non moi je
suis très content d'avoir ces deux
étoiles la rouge et la verte ensemble
c'est magnifique la deuxième étoile
c'est un c'est un niveau de cuisine
c'est des actifs encore plus grand c'est
des choix très difficiles que si on part
là dedans on peut plus revenir en
arrière en fait il y a pas de il y a pas
de retour et du coup moi je me ce qu'on
a nous voit très bien on va nous
continuer à se renouveler à s'améliorer
mais on va trouver d'autres objectifs
pour le futur alors on connaît bien
sans changer ce qu'il faisait
quand on fait de l'excellence c'est
parce qu'il a il dit qu'il prend
pratiquement que des produits biomé ils
essayent tous de faire ça quand on fait
l'excellence on essaye de faire
l'excellence à tout à tous les niveaux
donc tous les grands chefs font ça ils
n'en font pas forcément la publicité
alors dans une brasserie au coin de la
rue non mais sinon toute personne est
comme ceux qui font du vin je veux dire
on essaye alors je suis moi je vous dis
je peux pas vous le dire bio mais j'ai
j'ai deux traitements par an c'est à
dire ce qui est rien mais parce que
sinon je vais perdre ma mais mais mais
on essaye tous de traiter le moins
possible et quand mon vignerons m'avait
dit d'ailleurs le premier à qui j'avais
acheté qu'on a vu j'ai fait des carottes
quand même pour vérifier vignerons de
cette époque là il doit c'est pas vrai
il devait pas du tout il y avait rien il
y avait aucune trace dans sa terre de de
de de pesticides vous la connaissiez
l'étoile verte ça guide vos choix de
restaurant non non non parce que j'aime
vraiment manger les gens chez qui je
vais manger sont des fous de de ils le
font ils le font ils le font
naturellement c'est-à-dire que c'est les
produits qui vont chercher c'est les
produits mais vous ça c'est des produits
qui ça vous enfin c'est un choix de
restaurant d'aller là où c'est bio c'est
local c'est de saison où on recycle
l'eau on fait attention à la solidarité
c'est que l'eau pour l'instant j'en suis
pas là mais il se trouve que les
endroits où je vais manger
et j'ai la chance de pouvoir y aller
sont des endroits qui effectivement par
exemple ils ont leur potager
où ils ont donc circuit court aussi
enfin c'est quelque chose auquel vous
êtes tous ils essayent tous les
meilleurs essayent tous de faire ça
vraiment le le
talent qui fait la différence la
différence moi si vous me donnez les
meilleurs ingrédients je n'aurais pas
en avant c'est un signe d'État aussi
parce que maintenant on s'aperçoit bien
que c'est un c'est un avantage de d'être
en osmose avec la planète avec le
bien-être animal le bien-être humain
aussi parce que on sait que les
conditions de travail sont difficiles
bien sûr le problème c'est que c'est que
pour beaucoup de gens ça coûte très cher
c'est un un petit détail c'est pour ça
que sont étoile est importante pour lui
c'est qu'il va pouvoir continuer
justement à le faire parce que ça lui
coûte plus cher de faire de cette
manière là mais sinon tout encore une
fois l'excellence que ça soit dans le
vin que ça soit dans la nourriture ils
essayent tous de faire le mieux possible
donc le moins traité donc effectivement
voilà et vous vous allez souvent dans
des restaurants étoilés c'est vous aimez
aussi bien aller dans un petit bistrot
quand je parlais parce que j'ai commencé
à aller chez Virgin dès qu'il a ouvert
son restaurant il n'avait pas d'étoiles
après il en a une maintenant il vient
d'en avoir une deuxième
pareil chez lui il y a il y a que des
produits si je puis dire
mais il y a d'autres
et vous même dans votre consommation
vous faites attention à consommer de
saison parce que c'est ça qui est
important aussi c'est à dire que les
fruits soient de la bonne saison
j'ai des petits enfants qui qui
me réclame des des framboises au moins
il y a pas de problème parce que les
framboises moi j'aime pas ça donc
je trouve que c'est pas bon on t'a dit
qu'un abricot de saison
parce que il y a des très bons petits
sont tout petits donc il les trouve
merveilleux mais je dois dire que les
abricots du Roussillon va venir le
voilier va en pleine saison c'est
absolument extraordinaire et moi j'ai la
chance d'avoir énormément d'arbres
fruitiers chez moi donc on mange les
filles qu'on accueillit le matin ou même
juste avant le dîner parce que je les
mets au centre le basilic il est à la
maison les tomates enfin j'ai les
aubergines les les courgettes enfin j'ai
voilà j'ai tout ce qui est tout ce ce
qu'il faut faire
attention parce que je ne pêche pas
voilà et tout le monde a fini on va
présenter au dessert et c'est le péché
mignon
Brigitte j'allais dire est venu le temps
du sucré mais avec Carole Bouquet ça
c'est plutôt du salé en dessert qui a
choisi un fromage de caractère pour
terminer un repas ce repas le roquefort
ce fromage a pas de persillé laboré
exclusivement avec des laits crus de
brebis et ce pénicillum rock forty qui
donne au fromage ce goût unique fromage
dont on vantait les saveurs dès le 12e
siècle fromage totem de la région d'Eco
c'est vallées de l'Aveyron qui sont
reconnus dans le monde entier grâce à ce
roquefort pourquoi vous aimez tant que
ça le roquefort il vous rappelle pas
pendant rien là il vous rappelle la
France vous aimez tous les fromages
pratiquement tous les fromages
où vous le buvez à l'apéritif et en
Italie encore une fois on le mange tout
le temps l'apéritif se fait chez tout le
monde et on mange du parmesan et et du
jambon creuse c'est systématique il y a
aucune maison où ça ne se fait pas donc
on boit à ce moment là et sinon
en France on peut le faire aussi à
l'apéritif avec du comté mais alors avec
ça c'est extraordinaire avec du
roquefort c'est prodigieux et
j'avais pas décidé de faire du vin c'est
ça l'histoire c'est qu'il était pas
question que je fasse du vin à moi je
j'ai acquis c'était parce que j'ai
trouvé de plus en plus belle et comme
c'était à côté de chez moi je me disais
je vais pas voir juste quelqu'un à côté
de chez moi même si vous n'avez pas le
droit de construire je vais pas avoir
bon alors très existent c'est donc
j'achète j'achète j'achète j'achète
j'achète donc finalement j'ai 25
hectares mais donc toute une partie de
montagne et elle est vigne étant
abandonné je les remets en état après
les avoir remises en état je me demande
ce que j'en fais je me dis c'est dommage
donc je vends le raisin puis après avoir
vendu le raisin je me dis bon c'est
dommage je devrais faire du vin pour moi
et je vais chez quelqu'un faire du vin
et il lui en fait pour moi avec mais
avec avec mes raisins et je n'ai pas
aimé ce que j'ai bu et j'ai dit je je
sais pas ça que je voudrais boire c'est
chez moi c'est pas ça que je voudrais
mais vous saviez qu'il y avait ce
potentiel là sur vos vignes ou pas
la possibilité de faire un ventre j'ai
fait étudier
il se trouve que là moi c'est argile au
calcaire et indépendamment que ça soit
volcanique donc ça chez moi ça je savais
ce qui est très important parce qu'il y
a d'autres endroits où la culture est
plus facile sur l'île mais qui fait du
raisin de vraiment moins bonne qualité
beaucoup plus facile à travailler bien
évidemment mais là et je suis allé donc
j'étais chez quelqu'un et je leur dis je
m'écoutais comme j'aime tellement boire
je connais quelques zonologues en Italie
est-ce que je peux les appeler et puis
je l'amène chez je l'amène chez vous et
vous me faites une cuve pour moi il me
dit tu amènes quelqu'un chez nous tu ne
mets plus les pieds ici j'ai pas alors
très bien je vais vu les pieds ici je
vais monter un chèque ça m'est parti
comme ça je vais monter un chèque j'ai
appelé le neolog en question laquelle
l'un des plus connus en Italie on m'a
dit jamais te dire ah oui il m'a dit
mais oui je veux bien vous aider moi et
il est venu il a fait en un an alors
j'ai mis 10 ans avoir les permis pour
mes petites maisons en un an on a réussi
à construire un chat et on a et j'ai
fait du vin mais c'est parti comme un
vous savez comme
quand on dit à une voilà une petite t'as
pas le droit de jouer voilà tu as pas le
droit de jouer avec nous on retrouve le
caractère du fromage et de carottes
bouquet peut-être que vous avez goûté
mais c'est vrai que ça se marie très
bien mais chez Massimo Mori on dit aussi
que ça se marier très bien avec les
dessert on aurait pu aussi manger un
dessert mais
mais là c'est formidable
alors que là
je le mange alors que je dois aller
travailler et que alors vous savez
Carole Bouquet qu'on termine toujours
cette émission c'est bon mais c'est bon
mais c'est bon
oui parce que c'est vrai que je me suis
battu parce que justement normalement le
passé tôt qu'il faut emprunteria et très
doux et moi je voulais je voulais qu'il
soit équilibré qui est l'acidité qu'on
puisse le boire je voulais pas un bonbon
voilà je voulais d'ailleurs c'est pas un
sauternes qui est un peu plus sucré non
non on est vraiment dans ce pas si tôt
là qui est assez équilibré entre
l'acidité et la sucrosité on termine
toujours cette émission en musique alors
on va écouter musique que vous avez
choisi vous allez juste nous dire
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de composer pour être cuisinier
c'est pour ça
c'est pas du tout pour ça mais non
l'histoire alors qu'ils savaient
franchement très bien très bien écrire
de la musique j'ai une passion pour
essayer j'adore l'opéra italien alors
quand je parlais pas italien au départ
même les drames là c'est pas des drames
c'est aussi mais chez Verdi c'est des
drames je chantais à tue-tête pensant
que c'était des choses très joyeuses et
il va absolument manger
mais et ça c'est une musique que je
mettais tout le temps dans ma voiture
tout le temps tout le temps et à un
moment donné il y a un de mes fils qui a
fait un petit documentaire sur par
deliria qui est d'ailleurs sur le qui
était sur mon sur mon site de San
welloro et il est pas forcément
fanatique de musique classique et il a
entendu il pendant des mois parce
qu'après il a monté donc il l'entendait
pendant que je le mettais il l'entendait
pendant qu'il travaillait il l'entendait
quand il faisait le montage il en peut
plus du bas
merci Carole Bouquet d'avoir accepté
notre ami politique à table merci à chez
Françoise qui nous a cuisiné ce plat ce
bon poulet rôti et ce sangouédoro donc
le 24 le bouquet on va finir avec cette
belle couleur ambrée et ce vin de
Ponteilla courésie achetez-le il est
excellent merci à vous merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivis on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de politique à table sur LCP
[Musique]